hello everyone and welcome to our most
anticipated game uh from the seventh
mill twitter champions chester it's
magnus carlson versus the youngest uh
professor in the shenzhen university ho
yifan also the highest rated woman
player in the world uh
the highest rated active winning player
the highest rated is still you did
polgar
uh for uh you know just for your uh you
know
uh the pleasure of increasing your
knowledge the
unit's top rating was 27.35 so she was
able to cross
seven hundred whereas the iphone came
very very close to crossing twenty seven
hundred uh her top rating was twenty
six eighty six i believe uh and it was
in march 2015.
so uh very very close but uh you know
that now
she she's doing some other stuff so it's
hard to say if she will if she will
continue on that path but now
she's doing great he drew uh she drew um
uh
sally salem in round one and now she
faces magnus so let's see
uh how it uh how how it goes for her uh
so magnus with the white pieces opens
with
uh d4 we have knight to f6 by uh
ifan with c4 e6 uh knight to f3 and
d5 so the queen's gambit declined this
on the board we have knight to c3
and here c5 going for the cemeterish
defense with e3
and the captures on c4 we have bishop
captures in a6 so this is all very
standard stuff
uh uh you know thousands of games in the
database with this exact same position
so nothing new here
uh we have castles and b5 now attacking
this bishop
bishop back to e2 and ifan develops her
own light square bishop to this diagonal
so bishop to b7
we have d captures on c4 magnus offers
an early queen trade
as ifan is a fierce attacker and she
likes
you know madness on the board magnus
would very much like to take this game
into an end game right away
uh and uh she obliges with queen cactus
on d1
we have rook captures and the bishop
captures on c5 so again
nothing new is happening here uh knight
to d2
uh now shifting this bishop over to f3
maybe the counter uh carlsen's uh
e funds uh strong light square bishop on
b7 we have knight beat to d7
and now knight to b3 attacking the
bishop on c5 we have bishop to b6 and
now
a4 they are challenging those advanced
pawns on the queen side
we have b4 attacking the knight here and
now magnus goes for a5 saying okay uh
you can capture my knight i'm going to
capture your bishop here
uh ifan is not interested in that she
prefers to keep her bishop pair we have
bishop back to d8
and now knight the a4 now the knight is
uh well very strong here both of the
knights can now come to c5 maybe in some
lines even
even to b6 uh and here uh there are a
couple of moves you could play there
there is a known uh game
where bishop the e7 was played lauray
for fresney versus
sergey karakin in beijing in 2012 uh
where fresney was able to
uh beat carrick in uh after he played
this bishop to e7 move but here
ethan goes bishop to d5 she attacks the
undefended knight here
and now we have knight beat to c5 knight
eight to c5 is a known move
i was played in the baijin versus
zavangi in the 2017
uh team championship in china but here
we have knight beat the c5
and it is now only as of move 16 that we
have a completely new game so both of
them
very well prepared uh and magnus now uh
surprises
yifan with a new move so let's see what
happens here
uh we have bishop captures on a5 now the
pawn is undefended
bishop captures and now magnus is down
upon for the moment but
it will be very hard to keep both of
these pawns so bishop to d2
we have castles by ifa now she wants to
bring the outer rook into the game
and rook d to c1 uh
and now rook f the c8 uh just uh
uh you know allowing magnus to win back
the pawn it's uh
not easy to defend this pawn for example
if you just eliminate one of the knights
knight captures knight captures then the
bishop is under attack and then there's
a triple attack
will be on on the a6 pawn and there's
not much you can do
once you move it we're going to capture
this pawn and then again you have
problems defending this spawn
so ethan decides that it's best to just
giving up the pawn right away
uh we have bishop captures on a6 and now
rook to c7 as the rook here is under
attack rook to c7 bishop back to b5 by
magnus
and now knight captures on c5 we have
knight
captures and now h6 and here after
playing h6 efan says all right magnus
let's see let's see what you got
i'm very happy with my position can you
can you create some problem for me here
so here magnus goes knight to a6 now
there's an attack
on the rook but also there's an attack
on the bishop here on a5 so uh what can
ethan do
rook captures on c1 is pretty much
forced otherwise you can just resign
so rook captures on c1 rook captures
and now bishop goes back to b7 and this
bishop to b7
uh it's a it's a very nice move uh
because it's
uh it's the only move that uh really uh
keeps the game level for efan because
the problem is the b4 pawn is hanging
and uh
there's really no good way to defend it
other than bishop to b7 but bishop to b7
is a super tricky move and here she kind
of wants to trap magnus if magnus now
goes after the pawn
and plays knight captures on b4 then
what she planned was
knight to d5 now with a double attack on
the knight here
and after this knight is captured just
bishop captures on d2 with an attack on
the rook
and on the knight and now after rook to
d1
and now if the the knight is captured
magnus would capture here and she would
play
rook to a1 check and that's it magnus
can resign because
after the bishop blocks then bishop to
c4 with a double attack and now
white white resigns so this was ethan's
plan after bishop to b7 but magnus
saw through this and he didn't go after
the pawn he played knights to c5 now
attacks the bishop on b7 uh and here
bishop goes
back to uh to d5 here interesting was
knight to e4
simply because it attacks black's bishop
here or
why is it a dark square bishop here on
d2 and here after this gets traded off
then
pretty much you you can be sure that
you're not losing this game
uh but ethan played bishop to d5 and she
allowed
magnus a very tricky idea here magnus
played f3 i think he was very happy when
he
saw that he has the opportunity to play
this now knights the e4 will no longer
be possible and now
now yifan's position will be not as
great as now this pawn is coming to e4
and this bishop will not be a happy
bishop
so here uh she goes for b3 uh now she
offers a trade of uh dark square bishops
so bishop captures on a5
rook capture is now attacking the bishop
and the knight but now comes
bishop to a4 and this is what yifan
missed now the b3 pawn will fall there's
no way to defend it
and the problem is she's very low on
time magnus has some five
five and a half minutes on the clock she
has like uh something below two minutes
on the clock uh but the b3 pawn will
fall then magnus will start advancing
his past b
pawn so let's see uh if she can stop
this here she played king to
fade but this uh uh well this is uh
a very active move with the king uh it's
maybe maybe not enough there was the
bishop to b7
which is uh stupid to even consider but
it's uh
it's a nice move now if the knight
captures then you can capture the
uh the bishop on a4 and if if you don't
if you just go after the
pawn is continued then you can play the
rook here you attack the bishop you put
pressure on the knight so this can't
move this can't move
uh the the pawn will follow the bishop
moon so it would be a very interesting
position for black
but okay ephon went king to f8 and now
comes
e4 by magnus with bishop back to a8 like
i said
this is now a very sad bishop and
finally bishop captures on b3 magnus
considered it for a while but he saw it
was it was okay to capture the pawn
king e7 we have bishop back to a4 and
now the path is cleared for this pawn to
be
pushed forward we have rook to a7 and b4
now
we have knight the e8 now if wants to
bring the knight into the game to help
out with the defense of the
uh the of the pushing of the pawn but
now
bishop captures an uh e8 now magnus says
now it's time to trade and it's time to
have as uh you know uh as less obstacles
as possible for for my past pawn
so king captures now comes b5 we have
rook to c7 but
just b6 it's not a problem we have rook
to c8
and now there is only one move that wins
the game for magnus so feel free to
pause the video here and try to find
this idea while i give you a couple of
seconds
have at it
so for those of you who are able to do
it congratulations on finding this
incredible idea and for those of you who
just want to enjoy the show it's
king to f2 i'm only joking i i got you
again
i know it's not king to f2 it's actually
rook to a1
and now you will see the problem of the
light square bishop and it all came
you know very very suddenly this f3 e4
this bishop just
didn't have any squares it was at that
one point where even should have
exchanged those knights but
she allowed this expansion and now it's
all over
uh here if you capture the knight it's
not enough we can simply trade this
comes with
check king d7 b7 and there's no stopping
the queening of the pawn
so after rook to a1 bishop to c6 was
played not allowing the
uh pawn to be pushed to be to b7 to trap
the bishop and the rook but now comes b7
rook the b8 and here
rook to a6 and now you can see that the
bishop
really has no squares and he was in this
position on move
37 that hui fun resigned the game and
magnus wins uh
their uh well i don't know which
encounter this is between the two of
them i think it might be fourth
uh but i i could be wrong uh but yeah a
very nice victory and now you
although you can capture the pawn it's
simply not enough you can't capture with
the rook because you lose the bishop
and if you capture with the bishop just
rook b6 with a double attack on the
bishop here you just lose a piece after
the
the king moves came to e7 we're just
gonna pick up the
uh this uh well a piece and of course
we're we're going to win this we're up a
full piece
uh and on the other hand after rook day6
even if you don't grab this if you try
and bring
your king into the game then we simply
play rook captures on c6
so there's that and if you play
something like maybe
bishop to the d7 uh which kind of
kind of saves you uh then rook to a8 and
there's no defense against rook capture
some b8
uh or or you could move the the rook for
example but then we just
capture scatters and then bring a queen
into the game so whatever e fan does
she will lose the game so after rook to
a6 like i said she resigned in the game
so very very impressive for uh someone
who doesn't uh
i take chess all that seriously and is
accomplished on so many other
aspects of life she really really played
a great game and it all came down to
this one point
where uh she could have continued better
but
she simply allowed magnus too much after
this
bishop at the d5 move just
just a nice uh you know a counter attack
here after
uh after he attacked her bishop and b7
would be enough to trade pieces and now
this would be a very easy draw for her
uh but yeah that's all it takes for
magnus to you know cease his opportunity
and grab a full point and of course if
you want to play against the world
champion you
you you you you can't allow such things
uh but other than that a great game and
i hope you guys uh hope you guys enjoyed
it so that was a
a nice game from round two you keep
using hashtag suggestion uh so i can
check out some of the games that were uh
interesting to you as there are many of
them being played i
i you know can be maybe cover uh two
two or three while while they're being
played but i can't
see all of them so yeah once again hope
you guys enjoyed it
i would like to thank jorge campos david
traynor kevin stormeyer
paige myers and chingy chan for your
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot i really appreciate it
as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here thank you for
watching
and i will see you soon continuing the
coverage of this very nice tournament
checking up on your wonderful
suggestions and whatever else happens in
the chess world
so thank you all i will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day